L’économiste libéral Milton Friedman a
dit dans les années 1990 : « Si vous voulez
voir le capitalisme en action, allez à Hong
Kong ! »
L’économie de l’île est en effet très
dynamique et elle se caractérise par une
très faible intervention de l’État.
L’initiative privée et l’esprit commercial
y sont donc très développés.
Dans cette atmosphère particulière, j’ai
bien l’impression de voir la main invisible
d’Adam Smith.
Vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale,
la chaîne qui parle du meilleur de la pensée
sans vous prendre la tête.
Bonjour, je suis Romain, le créateur du site
1000 idées de culture générale et coauteur
du manuel du même nom.
Je vais vous parler aujourd'hui de l'idée
phare d’Adam Smith, qui est considéré
comme le père de l’économie moderne.
Dans son oeuvre maîtresse La Richesse des
nations, l'économiste évoque une force qui
guiderait le chef d’entreprise dans son
activité, LA MAIN INVISIBLE.
Depuis, cette image a été énormément reprise,
à tort et à travers, la plupart du temps
de manière assez vague, sans que l’on sache
trop ce à quoi elle correspond.
On a donc envie de se demander : mais qui
a vu la main invisible ?
La main invisible, elle a tout d’abord un
sens au niveau de l'individu : c’est ce
qui pousse l’homme à poursuivre son intérêt
individuel.
Adam Smith montre qu'on retrouve notamment
cette dimension dans l’échange.
En effet, dès lors qu’ils échangent, les
hommes ont besoin les uns des autres, ils
deviennent économiquement dépendants les
uns des autres.
Dans un échange, le vendeur et l’acheteur
s’apprécient peut-être, mais ce qui les
réunit, c’est que chacun permet de satisfaire
l’intérêt de l’autre.
Adam Smith dit même que c’est parce qu’ils
sont mutuellement égoïstes que l’échange
fonctionne si bien.
Vous connaissez peut-être son fameux exemple
du boucher, du brasseur et du boulanger.
Adam Smith veut montrer avec cet exemple que
le talent exercé dans un but égoïste - comme
l’expertise artisanale du boucher, du brasseur
ou du boulanger qui vise à faire du profit
- eh bien ce talent bénéficie au client.
La main invisible explique donc, sur le plan
moral, la contradiction entre l’égoïsme
de l’intention et l’effet altruiste de
l’acte.
Mais il y a plus : l’échange ne se limite
pas à une permutation de propriété, parce
qu’il implique toujours une forme de communication.
Pour Adam Smith, l’échange est aussi une
procédure de socialisation marchande, c’est-à-dire
qu’il crée de nouveaux liens sociaux, des
liens inédits.
La main invisible aurait donc aussi une fonction
à l’égard de la société tout entière.
La main invisible a également un sens au
niveau de la société tout entière : elle
régule de manière efficace les relations
économiques et sociales.
Pour bien comprendre la métaphore, il faut
en fait imaginer une main géante, invisible
bien sûr, qui pousse et déplace les individus
pour les faire interagir.
Pour trouver cette idée, Adam Smith s’est
inspiré de la fable des abeilles de Mandeville
(article sur le site) et des théories des
physiocrates (des économistes du XVIIIe siècle)
qui postulaient que l’harmonie sociale naît
du respect par chacun de ses intérêts propres.
Je vais vous lire le passage précis de La
Richesse des nations où Smith évoque la
main invisible.
En philosophie politique, la thèse de la
main invisible se nomme l’identité naturelle
des intérêts : pour chaque intérêt individuel,
il en existe un autre qui lui correspond exactement,
de telle sorte que la rencontre des deux acteurs
aboutit un bénéfice mutuel.
La métaphore de la main invisible dit donc
que c'est le marché, le lieu naturel d’organisation
des échanges, qui assure l’ordre social.
Enfin bon, est-ce que c’est vraiment le
sens que voulait lui donner Adam Smith ?
En fait, les choses ne sont pas du tout aussi
simples.
La réalité, c’est qu’il y a une disproportion
entre, d’une part, la prospérité de la
métaphore en économie, et plus généralement
dans l’opinion publique, et d’autre part
son occurence et son sens réels chez Adam
Smith.
Dans le détail, en effet, le père de l’économie
ne mentionne la main invisible… que 3 fois
! Une fois dans La richesse des nations (dans
le passage que je vous ai lu), une autre fois
dans son livre de philosophie morale, la Théorie
des sentiments moraux ; et enfin une autre
fois dans son Histoire de l’astronomie.
Alors, elle existe vraiment la main invisible
?
Les lecteurs d’Adam Smith qui se sont penchés
sur la question ont émis différentes hypothèses.
Je vais vous en donner 3 :
La métaphore renvoie toujours à l’idée
de coordination globale, mais elle aurait
un sens propre à chaque ouvrage dans lequel
elle est présente : un sens économique dans
La richesse des nations, un sens moral dans
la Théorie des sentiments moraux, enfin un
sens céleste (coordination des planètes)
dans l'Histoire de l’astronomie.
La métaphore aurait une fonction marginale
et rhétorique, c’est-à-dire qu’elle
ne renverrait à rien de précis mais servirait
seulement à convaincre le lecteur avec une
belle image.
La métaphore aurait une fonction ironique
: Adam Smith voudrait en fait se moquer des
individus qui croient en l’action, sur les
hommes, d’un principe supérieur et transcendant.
Bref, vous l’avez compris, la main invisible
comme métaphore du marché est davantage
un concept des lecteurs d’Adam Smith que
de l’économiste lui-même.
Ça ne veut pas dire qu’il n’est pas pertinent,
mais ça montre comment le laxisme intellectuel
et le temps peuvent transformer des idées
et leur donner une ampleur indépendante de
leur sens originel.
En résumé, la métaphore économique de
la main invisible avance que l’harmonie
économique et sociale résulte de la coordination
spontanée des intérêts individuels.
C’est pourquoi elle est souvent utilisée
pour légitimer la liberté économique : si
on laisse les agents économiques agir et
prendre des initiatives, alors l’ordre social
s’établira de lui-même, sans intervention
publique.
Alors, bien sûr, il ne faut pas croire en
la main invisible comme en une évidence,
parce qu’elle n’est pas exempte de critiques.
Je lui vois moi 2 limites principales :
Sur le plan logique, tout d’abord, on peut
soupçonner que qualifier un phénomène d’
« invisible », c’est un très bon moyen
d’en camoufler la probable inexistence - celui
qui croit en l’existence de la main invisible
s’en économise la démonstration.
Sur le plan historique, les marchés semblent
être des créations de l’État plutôt
que des phénomènes spontanés, ce qui voudrait
dire qu’il y aurait plutôt une main, celle-ci
bien visible, de l’État.
Après, on peut aussi trouver beaucoup d’exemples
de phénomènes spontanés de type main invisible.
Moi, je ne tranche pas.
Je trouve simplement - comme vous je l’espère
- que l’idée est intéressante et stimulante.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, mettez un pouce
bleu et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la prochaine.
Pour lire ma synthèse de l’idée d’Adam
Smith sur le site 1000 idées de culture générale,
voire pour pour lire l'ouvrage La Richesse
des nations directement (mais je ne vous le
conseille pas, peut-être juste des extraits),
les liens sont dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisées dans le format le
plus clair possible, vous pouvez vous inscrire
à la newsletter en laissant votre adresse
e-mail sur le site.
Enfin, je remercie mon très bon ami Yannick
B, qui m’a invité à Hong Kong.
C’est grâce à lui que j’ai pu obtenir
toutes les belles vues aériennes de la ville
de la vidéo.
Vous pouvez suivre son travail artistique
sur sa chaîne Instagram, dont le lien est
dans la description.
Je suis Romain et sous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous vous n’avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur
de la pensée.